[Applause]
thank you Andrew good afternoon
everybody uh on the 7th of July the
Prime Minister announced his resignation
as leader of our party
the 1922 committee then organized five
ballots over an eight day period
concluding the part of the leadership
election for which we have
responsibility
and putting forward the candidates to
the National Convention and cchq for the
program of hustings all over the United
Kingdom and the ballot of the membership
that has now concluded
I work closely with the board of the
party cchq and civica electoral services
to ensure that all qualifying members
had the opportunity to vote and to
ensure that our ballot was Secure as
well as free and fair I'd like to thank
the 1922 executive and in particular my
fellow officers and asgani will rag Sir
Jeffrey Clifton Brown
or Blackman and Gary sandbrook and our
staff for all of their help and support
especially during the administration of
the Parliamentary rounds of voting I
would like to thank the party board and
staff for all their hard work organizing
the hustings which allowed so many
members to see the candidates in action
whether in person or online I'm grateful
to CES for the professionalism with
which they have dealt with the ballot in
distributing collecting and Counting the
votes both online and by post
finally I want to thank all the party
members who have taken this
responsibility very seriously
all the candidates who put themselves
forward for election and in particular
my colleagues Rishi sunak and Liz truss
who ran such excellent campaigns in the
full glare of media scrutiny and who
showed themselves to be outstanding
candidates to be the leader of our party
[Applause]
[Applause]
now the result
I used to Graham Brady the returning
officer for the conservative and
unionist party leadership election
declare the total number of eligible
voters was 172 thousand
437. the turnout in the election was
82.6 the total number of votes rejected
was 654.
the total number of valid votes given to
each candidate was as follows
Richie sunac 60
399 Liz truss 81
326. therefore I give notice that Liz
truss is elected as the leader of the
conservative and unionist party
[Applause]
foreign
well thank you sir Graham
it's an honor to be elected as leader of
the conservative and unionist party I'd
like to thank the 1922 committee the
party chairman and the conservative
party for organizing one of the longest
job interviews in history thank you very
much
I'd also like to thank my family my
friends my political colleagues and all
of those who helped on this campaign I'm
incredibly grateful for all of your
support
I'd like to pay tribute to my fellow
candidates particularly Richie sunac
it's been a hard-fought campaign I think
we have shown the depths and breadth of
talent in our conservative party
[Applause]
and I also want to thank our outgoing
leader my friend Boris Johnson
thank you
Boris you got brexit done you crushed
Jeremy corbyn you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to Vladimir Putin
you were admired from Kiev to Carlisle
friends and colleagues thank you for
putting your faith in me to lead our
great conservative party the greatest
political party on Earth
foreign
that our beliefs resonate with the
British people
our beliefs in Freedom in the ability to
control your own life in low taxes in
personal responsibility and I know
that's why people voted for us in such
numbers in 2019
and as your party leader I intend to
deliver what we promised those voters
right across our great country
[Applause]
during this leadership campaign I
campaigned as a conservative and I will
govern as a conservative
and my friends we need to show that we
will deliver over the next two years
I will deliver a bold plan to cut taxes
and grow our economy
I will deliver on the energy crisis
dealing with people's energy bills but
also dealing with the long-term issues
we have on energy Supply
[Applause]
and I will deliver on the National
Health Service
but we all will deliver for all for our
country and I will make sure that we use
all the Fantastic talents of the
conservative party our brilliant members
of parliament and peers are fantastic
counselors are ms's
rmsps all of our counselors and
activists and members right across our
country because my friends I know that
we will deliver we will deliver or we
will deliver and we away
and we will deliver a great victory for
the conservative party in
2024. thank you thank you
foreign